Gary doesn't know I'm about to ask you
these questions do you Gary I prefer
improv and and surprises so I yeah I
could kind of tell you that kind of guy
I could kind of tell I'm actually just
gonna turn on my video camera here in
fact very quickly while I do this and
Garret and if you've got a camera at
your end feel free to turn it on if you
so desire so we could see you it's
always of course more engaging to
actually see who is speaking so there we
go hey how is man hands on this
afternoon it's really well good good
good
so without further or two sixty second
quiz no right and wrong tell us two of
the films that would be in your top ten
list of favorite films ever ironically
this is insane Chris because I caught
this as your pre slide my favorite
all-time film is Empire Strikes Back
it's just it's crazy that you brought
that up are we gonna get on besides that
you know I'm not a really a good film
guy I actually like tend to like most
films I guess the other feel you know
the other the two films that most impact
me top of mind were Empire Strikes Back
because I just moved to America and it
was like the first time I felt like an
American when that movie came out I was
five well I knew what I knew what the
other kids were talking about I'm like
yeah Darth Vader like it was meant to me
like I was in the loop right so that was
that and then the other thing was
Forrest Gump of course come came out in
1994 pre-internet for me I didn't even
know what I'm going to see I went with
20 of my high school friends we're about
to graduate where we just graduated from
high school and I was just blown away
and there was something different back
then you didn't know what you were
walking into right you know it back then
you didn't have the internet you didn't
know everything about the movie before
you got there and so the surprise of
what the story was Forrest Gump stands
out yeah that can you believe that's
over 20 years old as well and everything
about that the music and the story okay
so we just wanted a very quickly playing
a picture of you know Gary vanish our
Empire Strikes Back Forrest Gump are you
a dog man or a cat man
neither I don't like pets okay
introvert or extrovert would you say
next question massive massive extrovert
Downton Abbey or Breaking Bad you
haven't watched them second of either
show yet okay yet but you notice yeah
that's what TVs really changed isn't it
hasn't it though we can now kind of
binge view but wipe off three days from
our business unfortunately as a result
two more quick questions one of the
nicest celebrities that springs to mind
that you've met I'm sorry trap for a
second one of the one of the nicest
celebrities that you might omit or work
with it just springs to mind
hands down Ashton Kutcher hands down and
of course he wrote a very nice testimony
about you on on the back of your book
just as smart as it comes to start-up
entrepreneurship as anybody who's doing
it full-time and then when you take him
to account that he has to spend his time
as being a celebrity and doing the show
and what he does it's very impressive to
me had a great guy I thought was great
in jobs as well I know some people
slated the movie but you know the movie
listen and I told him I need to become a
friend the movie was ok he killed it Oh
unbelievable unbelievable and kids no
kids what's your kind of he'll you'll
personally yeah have you got kids - I'd
say Misha and Xander Misha is
four-and-a-half is he under is 18 months
girl boy beautiful
Wow now the only reason when he's gonna
throw these this this right hook if you
like for the you know the first 120
seconds let's say was because they may
seem like random questions I'm just
throwing out there but essentially what
we're really doing is is the nucleus of
pretty much everything that you talked
about in online and in your business
it's what I've learned a huge amount
from you and that's really engage with
your audience through stories and really
Jab Jab Jab right hook your current book
that's really I guess a central message
for those who may be unfamiliar with a
jab jab jab right book the right hook
your current book could you could you
kind of sum up the sent a message to
that place yes
/ listening you know the hundreds and
hundreds and thousands of you that are
on this and I see the numbers a lot of
you are trying to sell something now by
the way when I say sell something yes
that can be informational product yes
that can be wine yes that can be raising
money for charity yes that can be
parenting your kids you're selling right
you're selling chill to me to me why
I've been successful my career is I'm
always selling where people actually are
not where they used to be or not where I
wish they were and that's very important
and so what I did in Jab Jab right hook
is I wrote a book about the social
networks the eight or nine social
networks right now that are actually
platforms that a lot of us are spending
our time on a lot of us I mean we're our
eyes and our ears and and most of all
our attention has shifted dramatically
look there are there are an ungodly
amount of people right now watching this
Chris thirty years ago this technology
did not exist and it blows my mind
those people were reading a book on
their porch or watching television they
were at the movies you know they were
consuming content in a different way if
that's what they were doing
so what I'm focused on is Facebook
Twitter Tumblr Pinterest Instagram
LinkedIn snapchat vine Google+ these
platforms that everyday more and more
people are spending time on and what I
see is the hundreds of people watching
right now thousands of people watching
right now you mean the far majority most
people are struggling to figure out how
to make it work as a business see web
1.0 was easy search and email marketing
was easy it was direct conversion
socials heart and it takes implications
thus the title give give give and ask or
Jab Jab Jab right hook and so to me I
went through the book of a philosophy of
giving giving giving and then asking in
return not expecting Chris not expecting
in return
asking hoping for a commercial
predicated on how good you gave right
and number two I broke down the
platforms one by one and explained the
nuances of each platform and how to
actually story tell in them and I gave a
eighty case studies to help people
so what you're saying here is that the
the the jab jab jab of the title is is
essentially give give give and then the
right hook is and then ask for something
back in return is that really what
you're saying is the central message of
of successful marketing I think so I
mean listen I don't know much about
every detail of your world Chris but
here's what I know you have created a
platform where my time is very valuable
I get paid lots of money and don't do a
lot of stuff and you've been able to
bring me to your audience right now and
you know you're bringing value and it's
setting us all up we're all doing it
it's the reason I'm here there are
hundreds of people right now that I've
not heard of me you know Chris it's
amazing even for my million followers
and 150 TV appearances and all that you
know how it is still though now I mean
like it's incredible to you know back to
Ashton my favorite story tell anybody is
when the in Ashton went out to dinner
and the the waitress was more excited
that I was there I grew up watching Wine
Library TV and I looked at her and I
looked at her I was like I thought she
was joking I was like what are you
talking about arias that's kind of how
it works right like you know and so I
know that to be true and thus I want to
be here for the next 40 minutes that
bring as much value to this audience as
possible all I'm gonna do is jab I'm
gonna answer the questions I'm not here
to sell my book I know that happen later
should I do a good job and I answer
questions and I make them thinking and
you know me well enough to know I do
think I see the world a lot differently
than the majority of people that look
like me on paper I'm a different kind of
marketer I come from a much more of a
marathon long-term legacy lifetime value
percentage of wallet spend mentality I
am dramatically more patient than the
far majority of marketers and sales
people and business people in the space
right now and that's what makes it work
for me and that's how I feel comfortable
now that might be predicated because I
really build some big businesses you
know I probably you know in theory would
have been a little bit less patient if I
hadn't done well before but I was
patient from the beginning even building
the wine business it's my natural state
it's my DNA I feel uncomfortable taking
before I give and I think that's
something people need to think about you
see well I like about you you you back
it up with
actions that you know talk is cheap it's
very easy particularly let's say using
facebook it's pretty easy to say the
right thing and a person's true
character is determined by you know what
they do not what they say so here's a
perfect example what I mean by that is
you know 45 minutes you there's nothing
to sell as we said I've even said this
in the in the invitation we're gonna
hopefully just entertain and give some
value and that's kind of the whole gist
of it you also hit on something you know
I'm just gonna say right here for
everybody really understand I think
everybody who's watching has been in
that place where especially when an
author comes on like I am right now with
the end of the book it's a whole sales
pitch yeah and listen guys by the way if
I thought it let me see this cuz I want
everybody to know who I am if I thought
that would work I would do it that's the
irony ironic ironic thing if you
actually kind of do marketing this way
you do give give give actually making
the sale is actually ironically not that
difficult if you treat your lists well
when the time comes to it your list will
be good to you back it is not Chris my
book three months later is still on the
top 500 books overall on Amazon where a
lot of other people that give advice
about how to sell books and mark it they
get on number one on that first day
because they blast everybody right and
then you look at their books a month
later then there are three thousand ten
thousand forty thousand a hundred
thousand right we've all seen these
characters come and go for me I want to
be around fifteen years from now I want
today to be the first day of hundreds of
people becoming aware of me for the rest
of their lives I want them to engage
with me I want to bring value my sales
will come it's so easy it just it's so
clear to matrice I want to go back to
the Thank You economy for a moment
because that was really really resonated
with me and it was something I'm gonna
paraphrase is very badly I'm sure but
there's something that you sit in that
book and you said something along the
lines of you're talking about how people
decide if they were you talking about
business of course but you said you
broke it down he said how do people
decide if they they like each other they
listen they talk they communicate in a
relationship develops it's exactly the
way same way online that we should
communicate with our customers or future
customers but you said that the key here
is really if you're brave enough to
expose a little bit of heart and soul I
do remember that sentence and I had to
put the book down I thought you know
what if you're brave enough to expose
little bit of heart and soul and some of
question to you Gary is how about people
that are in business that feel like you
know I don't really know what I have to
say you know I don't really feel I'm
interested in business but I don't
really feel I have you know something to
say what would you say to those people
then you're gonna lose you know I mean
and and it's a it's a pretty you know I
hear this all the time you're like Gary
you know I don't know what I can add I
don't know what to put out and I'm like
well then you're probably not gonna win
you know like you know I think where
people are very confused is this notion
I want everybody to kind of wrap their
head about what I'm gonna say if you do
not bring value you lose now you can
bring value in a lot of ways i watch a
lot of people who are bringing value as
curators an access givers I mean Chris
that's what you're doing here you're
curating good content
I've been lucky I have original thoughts
you know that's happened for a long time
in my career I'm a fast mover you know
vine comes out and I'm using it for a
week from 11:00 p.m. to 3:00 in the
morning
not for my health but because when
people ask about mine I want to be an
expert in my craft you know I don't have
a lot to add to economics conversations
or I don't have a lot to add in farming
conversations and I don't have a lot to
add in 99.9% of the genres and that's
why I don't make money on them like at
the end of the day you have to add
something now
by the way adding Hope adding curation
adding humor there's a lot of things
that can be added but if you do not
understand what you can say or what you
can bring to the table well then that's
where the problem starts that's not the
issue that's not the current issue
that's the global issue I mean Chris I'm
gonna tell you something right now and
maybe I'm ranting a little bit here I'm
really pissed off with how many people
our marketing experts have big podcasts
all this stuff that I've never sold [ __ ]
in there right I've never run a business
in their life that only you know matters
to me like like good and and so I think
you have to have chops now if you are a
great host if you're a great curator of
information the world's fast now so if
you're good at going around the web
finding the right things and the right
information we
packaging and selling it your
distributor I respect that but you have
to bring value and by the way talking on
social networks just might not be what
you bring value in it's not for
everybody you know I'm I think in quick
terms which is why Twitter short quick
bursts
that's why Twitter works for me I am an
extrovert and a ham and that's why I
like the camera right you know and so
I'm just mapping to my strengths so I
implore Chris every one of friends that
are listening around please please with
all your heart be honest with yourself
be self-aware figure out what you're
good at
don't try to copy the crisp blueprint
don't try to copy my blueprint you know
I'm very unique I get scared when people
try to be like me there's a lot of other
people to be better you know there's a
lot of other people that people should
be in emulating than me cuz I'm extreme
I'm an extreme workaholic I'm extremely
interested in getting my hands dirty
engaging at scale hustling when it
doesn't seem like there's value in it
because I'm playing a fifty-year game
that's not for everybody let's talk
about you you briefly alluded to to
video a moment ago now let's talk about
video because one thing that I've
enjoyed very much about your video
presentation style is the fact that to
coin the phrase you knew you are the guy
that is ready fire aim your out there
let's just do it I think a lot of us I
saw this when I started have that red
lights intro and the red light goes on
you say something then a dog barks or a
plane goes overhead or you don't even
like how you said the inflection on the
word so you do the video again I sort of
video view once when I start online in
2008 of you walking down the street in
New York
tons of people people look at you you
walk past like who's this lonely just
talking and you didn't miss a beat and
that kind of was like wow you gave me
and I guess a lot of other people
permission just to do it so for those
that are watching this webinar right now
that you know they kind of got this
passion but they're still kind of that
that hesitancy to actually push kind of
go what would you what would you say to
those people that I think there's a lot
less risk to try something once than
people think you know like I'd you know
go back and watch episode 1 of Wine
Library TV you know I was reserved I was
scared to lose my customers because I
didn't want them to know how Lumi I
really
you know at the end I say things like
you know we're probably gonna make a lot
of mistakes I don't know how this is
gonna work out hopefully I'll be back
tomorrow and it became the you know
start of me being on online video every
day of my life almost since then I will
say this Chris I think the way you
framed that question here's what I would
say I am if I can make anything happen
during our time together on this weekend
it's gonna be this moment I'm gonna say
something the the biggest profound thing
that I think I say publicly and it's how
I live my life and I don't actually talk
about this too often Chris so I think
you've done a good job to get me thank
you for being prepared to share I'm far
more worried about the last 10 years of
your life than the next 10 say this
again you'll FOMO worried yes about the
last 10 years of everybody's lives here
then I am about the next 10 years what
would you mean by that I mean that
regret is the scariest thing a human
being can deal with and so the reason
I'm always willing to take chances and
do things is ah there's I'm an old soul
something weird happened to me I I'm an
old soul a true one like when I fly on
planes I gravitate towards sitting with
80 90 year olds I always did this I
always my mom even tells me I was like a
five year old I'd go to the park and
literally go sit down with the oldest of
old people it was just weird and I would
just talk to them and I've always been
that way
I think I'm an old man from day one and
so what that does is I've had a lot of
conversations in the last decade with 70
80 90 years old individuals and
something keeps coming up Chris it's
it's them wishing they were the amount
of times the word wish Wow comes up when
you talk with somebody who's 70 80 90
versus not is is flabbergasting as it
wish they had done something that they
hadn't done that's right
nobody says I regret not I regret doing
no nobody says it nobody when I sit down
and I'm good I'm a loser I'm a
psychologist right so when I sit down
they start telling me their life I never
hear somebody say you know you know I I
wish I didn't you know do like it yeah
yeah they're always like I wish I was
just spend more time my family you know
I wish you could they go a little more I
wish I'd taken that rib yeah risk I wish
I asked that girl out I wish I wish I
did videotape that one time when I had a
hunch that I could have been a you know
I I wish I mean it's good I wish I did
start a Facebook account three years
earlier because I would have been big
you know I you know it's lit these
things that I keep thinking about the
people are sitting with right now like I
wish I did email that person and ask
them guys here's a good one for
everybody's watching think of three
people that you desperately want to
connect with literally go find their
email because you can email them right
after this video right now email them
and say hey Tim Ferriss I won't have
lunch with you
by the way 99.99999% of time you will
not get it but that point one its
game-changing it can be so whether it's
mark human or whether it's Chris sorry
Chris I just could sent you a bunch of
emails a day should I say no all the
time because I don't have the time of
course but once in a goddamn blue moon I
say come to Boehner for five minutes you
know and I did that once this year last
year and it turned into Chris is there a
way to share a URL with anybody here yes
we could I'm gonna awesome if we you can
type it in the you can tell me I'll get
type in the chat window on the right
hand side I don't if you can see that
yes yep so I'm just gonna put this up
Toriko
created this company great story great
story though it was that Commodore Co no
doc dot Co dossier um you know it's just
so interesting to me I took this meeting
and now I have a multi-million dollar
agency that represents the top
celebrities on vine and this was as the
result of an off the chance email saying
can i you know hang out scarier than
that it's off the chance of a kid
his hand at a Toronto keynote and said
can I get 30 minutes of coffee with you
in New York and I said no on stage in
front of thousands of people he said
what if I beat you in
rock-paper-scissors
ha ha ha I love the kids I go what yeah
what if I beat you rock paper scissors I
said okay he gets on stage and Chris you
know me a little bit if I beat him I
would never see him I was never in the
world see him but he beat me and we had
the strengths that it led to a
multi-million dollar company so you know
in six months so you know you just never
know insane and by the way what makes
Mark Cuban what neck makes Seth Godin
what makes these people what they and
then and then all the sucks and the ever
Williams is and all the tech people in
Silicon Valley that I care about what
makes these people is them taking those
random meetings I I guess what it comes
down to me from egress is you've got to
take your app back you got a swing you
just have to that's what I want
everybody knows that this is you get one
of that and it's funny to loop back to
what you're talking about regrets
there's there's a there's an amazing but
you're probably very called the top five
regrets of the dying very depressing
title but it's a bit by the way I want
to I want to expose myself you you kind
of jumped and said I'm sure you are you
know you read well read like six books
in my life so okay well essentially it's
a it's about a woman who is a
professional care and she looks out
people in their 80s and the 90s and she
just says what you said there's a common
theme and that I think my biggest fear
it sounds like you're the same as you
know I don't want to be that guy that's
80 and just thinks oh if only I don't
even mind if I try something didn't work
I just don't want to say I didn't I'm
gonna see this this is something again
I'm in the zone today some of these
things I haven't really talked about a
lot maybe here and there you just asking
the right kind of questions and tone of
an interview I guess good on you I
literally love losing let's just frame
that so everybody Heather correctly you
literally love losing when it comes to
business and sports that's why I love
the Jets so much
I love the process of the climb far more
than the spoils of victory I have liked
the last two years of building
vaynermedia my new agency being the low
man than totem pole in the agency world
much more than the last five years of
being big man in the wine world
I like that nobody knew who I was in the
agency world I like that there's
multibillion-dollar Sir Martin Sorrell
WPP Omnicom billion-dollar public
companies in the game I like that
everybody when I first announced it was
like oh you think because you have a lot
of Twitter followers you could build an
agency I loved being underestimated I
loved using clients because I didn't
know what I was doing at first I loved
it a true entrepreneur a real business
builder loves losses on the table I need
those check marks on the table they
drive me there my oxygen I prefer to
take a step back I like losing money
it's good it's it's it's humility it
reminds you you're playing the game it
uh it's the right thing to do like if
you're bad and you're not good enough
you deserve to lose it feels fair and
inspires me to be better every day
salute me if I may pick you up on that
you just thought about really enjoying
the climb I loved that a great great
kind of you know image very strong
striking visual but um how much of that
is do you think in your DNA and your
your parenting and how much of that is
just the fact that you just want to be a
success full business guy do you think
its inherent in you as a kid you know
emigrating from yes from the last I
think this has been map right like even
though I've never read it this nature
nurture thing it's been mapped right and
I think you know the DNA versus
parenting environment thing has been
long figured out and I agree with it
which is you know I'm a product of all
my realities yes a ton of it was
naturally in me but I'm sure this insane
hunger this underdog mentality even when
I'm winning even when or you know what's
even scarier Chris I'm now
psychoanalyzing myself
I'm like did I leave the wine business
cuz I was at the top that I needed to be
the underdog I didn't like being up
there right she answers yes to be honest
with you okay I have you know I liked
being you know I loved high school being
not popular freshman year and then being
really popular senior year I loved that
climb I like that I like that kind of
stuff I it's how I'm wired I think it
has a lot to do with being an immigrant
coming to America with no money you know
not speaking the language kids making
fun of me for not speaking the language
you know kids making me drink piss out
of a Pepsi can you know like being a
little guy you know yeah I love that
stuff I I live for it I live for it can
I ask are you old but I apologize my
parents you know hard work was in our
blood like we came here with nothing I
watched my dad work every hour of his
life it felt normal hard work was
instilled you know my mom did an
incredible my mom such a amazingly warm
human being so you know it's really
interesting my mom and dad and the
environment you know I think of myself
as a contradiction Chris I am fiercely
competitive and have a humongous ego I
want to win I want to win I know I'm
good I got it right at the same token
and I think you know it's fun for me to
have a relationship with you because
it's a new one it's a lightweight one we
don't know each other super well but I I
think you tell from like LA and from
right now and from probably what you've
heard of friends that were both close to
I'm also a good dude
like I I want to build the biggest
hereness he was the thing I love more
than anything in the world ready I want
to build the biggest building in town I
want to build the biggest building in
town
however I only just want to build the
biggest building in town I don't want to
build the biggest building in town by
building a nice building and then
tearing all the other buildings down and
that's how a lot of people there's two
ways of achieving it yeah and I want you
to build the biggest building and I want
Lois house to build the biggest building
and I want Tim and Godin and then I want
Kuban and then I want all those Silicon
Valley friends I have and the VCS Fred
Wilson and grease and Conway layer front
I want them to all but all the biggest
buildings I want them all to be super
happy and healthy
and family and rich and fun and success
I just want more I just want to be
better not because I want anything cause
I think a lot stuff I don't watch I
don't fancy car I don't need anything I
love the game Chris I love the game let
me ask you to your if I may are your
parents still alive yo yeah my parents
are very young like my dad 60 I came my
mom's 58 so very much alive you know now
that I've been removed a little bit from
the wine business my dad's you get more
involved in the wine business again so
more active they're going into a great
chapter in our lodge they've worked
their face off to bring my family to
America and now hopefully you know I'd
like to see them spend a little more
time and enjoy it a little bit do you
think they understand what you you've
got a brother's little AJ but do you
think they understand what you're doing
do you think they get you know what Gary
has done
I don't think technically like the
details [ __ ] I don't think most people
watching this know what I've done
right from a detailed standpoint from a
holistic standpoint like the
achievements they knew this was gonna
happen before I did they had been my mom
called me a star since I was eight years
old she knew she knew so I'm very aware
of everyone's time
and we're at 30 minutes in so we've got
another 15 and I wanna say let you get
back to your day as well there's nothing
worse is that some of these jumps of
webinar says it's 45 minutes is an hour
and half so we're not gonna do any of
that let's just loop back to jab jab jab
right hook again everything comes down
to storytelling but how can you without
wanting to sound crass almost how can
actually make money with that knowledge
well I think you know I think listen
crass what are you talking about Chris I
mean I think I think one of the things
that I'm most proud of is everybody
likes me because I sound like Mother
Teresa 90% of time but I'm the biggest
salesman in the block right I'm trying
to sell stuff I don't think it's grass I
think it's awesome I love
entrepreneurship I love selling to me it
comes out of bringing value you know
like okay for all the people that are
here that are b2b people here's the
number one thing you should do you
should go to LinkedIn you should find
the name of the person that you're
trying to sell to most of you should
know that if you're b2b because you know
the buyer is of whatever you sell you
may know the title it might be the
Vence manager you find them all you then
find their name then you take their name
you know Gary Vaynerchuk and you posted
into Google Gary Vaynerchuk and then
space Twitter right you say Twitter
right so you do that and then what you
do is you find them on Twitter 25% of
the people that you're looking to sell
to will have a Twitter account and then
you follow them and then you wait for
them to talk so if you're trying to sell
me Wow hit me up cold you don't get me
up cold you just watch what I said sure
I'm gonna say something tomorrow about
the Jets and then you jump in totally
and then you say hey Gary Gary smalls
fan yeah that's right and now you and I
made a first connection on something I'm
passionate about instead of you trying
to pitch me on something how often do
you see that happen to you is that
certainly the minority or are people
getting a bit more savvy and actually
you know engage and really I on the
other hand and doing it heavily and I've
landed multi-million dollar accounts
that way I've consulted some friends to
do it this way they're killing it and I
out of the passion to bring value to
this audience hold of six people here
because listen I'm very realistic most
people don't want to put in the work
they want to watch webinars real read
books complain about it not happening
they don't want to put in the work I
know that six people I hope that six
people here take my advice honest after
seminar you know whether it's Monday
morning cuz they wanna enjoy family time
when right now start realizing what are
you really selling to go to LinkedIn put
together 100 500 people's names go to
Google have the word Twitter then find
74 of them on Twitter follow every one
of them and then over the next couple
weeks engage with them around things
that that person cares about outside of
the business which inevitably is going
to lead to whether it's a month from now
or two months now you're opening to jump
in you know if I tweet it right now who
knows somebody who provides Internet
access
when I get replies on Twitter I'm gonna
reply to the person that I've seen
before do you have coos so that was me
Chris right there trying to spend three
minutes giving actionable tangible
advice that's what I call a jab that
works that's value it
cost you nothing and now it has set me
up in the future somebody hears like
move it's a good idea wait Chris to
somebody here in two weeks lands a fifty
thousand dollar account or a million
dollar deal because of that move then
they're gonna follow me with more arcs
right they're gonna love me I just gave
them something now and a year when I
come back out with my fourth book
they're gonna be like oh I've to buy
like 50 of these I got me a million
dollars why do you think it is that the
whole hard work thing is I mean we could
say this has been like it's innocent
since the dawn of time but I'm
definitely seeing maybe it's because the
internet has the perception therefore
it's quick and it's easy but there's
definitely a sense of entitlement these
days I to see the Internet as a tool
that allows us to do things you know
faster but it's still a learning curve
it still took me an awful long time
before I made any money online why do
you think it is that that many don't
really want to put in any hard work at
all nature just super complicated right
I think I think that they I think that
um you know I think about this all the
time I don't think I just think it
doesn't come natural to them it's the
same reason Chris that I want to work
out every day and have muscles and a
chest for the first time in my life and
be healthy and better cardio and live
longer and I'm not doing it while I'm
fighting I'm trying yeah certain things
don't come naturally but that doesn't
mean you shouldn't work for them what
didn't come natural to me was what came
natural to me was being full of [ __ ] but
over the last 20 years I converted
myself into being zero full of [ __ ] what
didn't come natural to me was being
organized but in the last seven years
through an assistant and Google Calendar
and other things I'd become organized
you know you just you have to fight
otherwise you don't get the results or
two I'm gonna do Gary I'm gonna do I'm
gonna ask Greg who's our moderator Greg
ray who's fielding questions behind the
scenes here to quickly jump on because I
did promise that we had some questions
that some would like to ask you and
we've got about we've got about seven
minutes left so mr. ray Greg ray make
thirsty can you hear me
young mr. Rey I can hear you mr. Farrell
hello Gary how's your day thank you for
these questions yes so is there kind of
an overriding theme to some questions
that we can throw it Gary
there's a few here and now that you said
questions tons are rolling in so I'll
try to adjust but the first one was Gary
you spoke in 2011 about concentrating on
context and not so much in content do
you still believe the same in 2014 I do
I think context I listen they both
matter the problem is that everybody
focuses on content
everybody talks about content nobody's
talking about context the context
matters right like even the look like
what's going on with this video right
like we were not on video at first it
was gonna be audio I'd never done video
with GoToMeeting before Chris thanks for
showing me the speech I think existed
you know and it changed it now a lot of
people have seen my face so I've
actually been able to say different
things different things think about what
I'm about to tell you I've said
different things because I knew my face
could do the work now instead of my
words
context context guys regulation Greg
well said if I were a newbie in the
social network marketing adventure tell
me the best platforms to learner master
you mentioned a couple LinkedIn and
Twitter there any other suggestions it's
completely predicated Greg on what
they're selling right so if you're
selling something to 12 to 18 year-old
children you'd be on snapchat you need
to be on vine you need to be on
Instagram if you're something selling to
60 to 80 year old females you'd be on
Pinterest you need to be on Facebook
so with Jab Jab right hook I went after
all the ones that I think are relevant
but it's completely predicated on your
target audience actually on that note
let me ask you with Facebook in mind
have you found that if you're a
personality you obviously have a fan
page but if you found that your personal
profile now that we can have followers
is essentially the same as a fan page
and would you therefore recommend that
maybe don't need both or or not no I
think the fan I think that actually
isn't working really well you know the
personal pages where people can follow
it I don't think it's working super well
with edge rank I think you're far better
off with a with a with an actual page
okay getting much more exposure i'm
stiii get way more engagement on my page
than I do with my personal page that has
followers I'm not even sure my personal
page with followers is working just you
know yeah you know I don't know if
you've tested both or you've seen it but
it doesn't look like anybody's personal
pages are doing well it's almost like
it's almost like it's functioning not
working so we have four minutes left so
Greg maybe you could pick maybe a couple
more questions and then we'll wrap up if
that's working for everybody
absolutely so you've talked a little bit
in this about you've got to get after it
you've got to hustle so we've had a
couple of people ask about what's the
what's how do we navigate that fine line
between hustling and being pushy or
overbearing with people nice question
that takes a very interesting skill that
takes tact that's like you know in guys
and girls you know dynamics that's
called charming or smooth right that's
just skill that's tact that's years of
practice that's
EQ that's intuition that's empathy
that's self-awareness that's the stuff
regular I think is becoming more and
more important in the world and so you
know the answer is different to everyone
sometimes I look too close immediately
because it feels right sometimes I slow
roll it for four years and everything
else in between so I you know I think
that's a skill that's like saying how do
I get better at singing well you can
take singing lessons but talent has to
be part of the equation some people just
don't have it I mean we all know people
that are just lost right like you just
watch the way they move around and
you're like oh my god there's Matt how
you trying to sell about how you try to
ask for the bait or going for the kiss
or you know I mean it's all that stuff
right so I don't know if that's teach mo
but what I will say is this if I have
one tangible answer to it
do what you want you know their old
sayings act like you would want to be
acted upon right you know like the
reason I think I'm a good salesperson is
I'm a good customer I know like what I
feel when I get approached and so that's
what I look for absolutely very very
good so I think the last and perhaps the
most important question that anybody is
asked here Gary is they say they're
being a little bit cheeky but I think
it's a good question what would you
recommend is a good Spanish red surprise
event I have one question about wine
sofa very hot on the wines from Tokyo
are oh very big ripe fruit under priced
in my opinion so Toro wines is where I
want everybody to check out tio ro I
also want to say Chris Greg anybody
who's listening that's on Twitter I want
you to say hello because I got a few
minutes here as I'm gonna walk down a
street for 15 minutes with my phone so I
can say hi
not all right Gary Vee maybe use a
hashtag Chris is the best
well Greg thank you back to you Chris
thank you great thank you for honoring
behind the scenes I appreciate you thank
you very much so where we are kind of
almost at art and our time and remember
in delivering happiness Tony Hsieh the
guy behind Zappos for those that may be
unaware who he is a billion dollar brand
talked about delivering Wow through
service and I think Gary Vaynerchuk is
actually just a guy that kind of
encompasses that I've seen you speak a
few times we've met met briefly a few
different times and I just want to say
Gary you know you really as a server Lee
you know it's easy to talk the talk
these days it's very easy to send your
Facebook wall I crushed it all these
great testimonials you know him so
boring so dull when people say that you
know as we said a person's true
characters defined by what actually do
and you certainly are doing exactly as
you spoke about look at this hasn't even
mentioned you know your book for sale
obviously if you haven't bought it we'd
like to encourage that just go to Amazon
as the best place Jab Jab Jab right hook
I have my copy right here there you go
so so Gary with all that said we're at
45 minutes past and I just want to
appreciate you know Saturday afternoon
you got your two kids here at home in
Manhattan and you gave up your time so
thank you sir appreciate it thanks Chris
I really appreciate it
you know super impressed by your
audience that that came out and so I
wish you nothing but the best and all of
you guys who've been watching think
about a couple of big things that at bat
this is our chance guys we have so lucky
our parents and grandparents didn't have
the internet we had a stay in our local
towns we had a limb are practical lives
our dreams were contained to our dreams
we need to execute we need to take
advantage but we have to bring value to
the people that we're trying to sell
please you're not entitled to that
dollar you need to fight for it gosh I
feel inspired
Gary P great spending time with you
thanks so much you're the best me up on
twitter guys gary vee i want to say hi
to some of you take care thank you thank
you so Gary's gonna disappear and all
that remains for me to say is thank you
very much for giving up your time today
hope you've enjoyed this this kind of
peek behind the the the genius really
you know it's it's not luck allows you
to come to a country we didn't read well
on this that much but he came from
Belarus in Russia not speaking English
came over here as a kid with his brother
and his parents you know learnt the
language hustled started working in his
dad's liquor store eventually took that
business online went to sixty million
dollar business and is now doing the
same for his digital consulting company
called vaynermedia off the back of that
has picked up a lot of celebrity and
well-known clients and is teaching them
essentially to do what we've spoken
about over the last 45 minutes how to
engage our story how to harness the
power of social media to to tell our
story and to grow our brand so thank you
for your time it's been super nice
spending it with you I'm just gonna
quickly look at the questions here and
if we have no more business I think that
is it as I say there's nothing to sell
in this webinar if of course you want to
buy Gary's book we're not trying to make
you buy it but if you're interested
amazon.com Jab Jab Jab right hook I
don't even know the price actually 15
bucks I think this has been recorded so
I will be sending out the recording of
this and again I want to be very
respectful of your time so
I'm gonna wrap it up now 46 minutes pass
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
thank you Gregory for moderating my name
is Chris Farrell this is Farrell signing
out for now speak to you soon take care
bye my